right mark you see me [ __ ] what did you
do L ha ha ha dan dan dan dan yeah yeah
oh my god so hard oh hello everybody my
name is markiplier and we spent the past
half-hour trying to find each other
again it was oh man it was awful but now
we have a system that actually works so
hopefully we'll be able to do it again
good times right volley fun fun fun okay
so in the time that we were spent trying
to find each other we actually learned a
lot about the game didn't we learn how
big the stupid map is yeah well that's
beside the point what we else learned it
did was that we need supplies is--is was
it that black rock that you hit and yeah
let's go I'm gonna get some wood okay
you get wood I got right into this Oh
and one of us might die and all hell
breaks yes at least we know what to do
and how to find each other and really
kind of sulfur or metal it'll be 100%
effective every time oh man gosh you'll
never have an issue again we're gonna
find each other it's gonna be okay oh
I'll always find you mark yes thank you
Bob
anyway we're finally god damn yeah that
was so long we were just sitting here
all it was we're singer like Oh what do
you see oh no you should cut some you're
wrong I was just gonna be like I feel
rock what do you see now so I see the
big mountain it's over there yeah
where's the Sun in relation to that
mountain directly over me oh I see
several rocks oh I was just there I'm
gonna kill myself I saw you kill
yourself come on man alright that's not
worth my time
alright there's a whole field of like
where where'd you go I went towards the
mountain there's a whole field of like
there's a rock file there's okay there's
no animal many moles will be fine we got
it now I'm actually do we we were
looking at the wiki is this right way
yeah going in towards the mountain II I
mean
I'm smashing a stone yeah so when you
gonna get stone we're gonna get metal or
we're gonna be you have so do you have
some stones already cuz you can make a
stone hatchet at that point oh okay yes
I do it's in survival it's not in
weapons oh I don't have enough wood I've
got a bunch here come here let's go
oh come here I'm right here okay where
oh hey hello mister you're fast Wow
no please put through put the rock down
honey there you go
okay would times 48 okay stone hatchet I
don't have enough for two so I've got
more wood if you have enough stone for
two
no I don't have enough don't okay well
you keep it then I'll get some more okay
thanks well do you want to get that deer
then I don't know how fast these deer
are gonna be but you want to get it
where is it it's over here by the
woodpile oh I can't run when I'm
crafting I'm gonna kill that boar though
okay I'm gonna go for the deer first and
then you be like your cavemen come on
it's fast Jesus Christ we're gonna go
I hear you yelling and that are all
around us here dump dump dump dump dump
I'm going for the boar it's easy
whoomp whoomp look at the whoop on this
alright oh yeah you have fun dear
yeah oh my god it's so brutal just boom
boom good god I love it awesome kind of
disturbing kind of oh well are you wait
are you oh I'll I'll help you or hurt
you I don't know what I'm over for the
deer goods let's murder the time all
right fine fine come here come here I'm
gonna hit you I swear I'm gonna round
I'm gonna cut it off in front of it okay
come on herd where'd my hatchet go oh
come on
here pit yep come on I got it already
fine whatever I'll help you the goddamn
go whomp on this [ __ ] God ever made
that sound effect is a wah
Oh
no it just found each other I mean ah
come on come on with my hatchet oh I
died I spun into death I'm gonna run no
you're not gonna make it they're gonna
kill you
damn it we're all sir old like 10 people
we just don't have to ride it oh my god
god I killed myself I did not kill
myself
you shut your mouth okay so now comes
the extremely long journey of finding
each other again I am very far Xenophon
I know you I know Danny oh well you
gotta be old sourpuss it's okay
is it it's okay it's all right don't
worry about him madam I mind ah Brian
Regan you son of a we have to taking
consolation guys like comment and
subscribe if you hate those guys just
write down in the comments about how
much you you despise everything about
that everything that they stand for they
are horrible human beings find their
MySpace pages and just write the most
hurtful thing you can think of out there
yeah yeah you'll be able to find it
there'll be the only ones on there but
they'll be bragging about how they shot
completely unarmed defenseless guys with
guns a huge distance when they were
playing the rust alpha the other day
yeah on the server uswest pvp you we
know who you are everyone everyone's
gonna get right on that
you guys are gonna have so many negative
comments no we're gonna find your reddit
user names and you're gonna get no karma
I should look over there I keep looking
over here but I know that your webcam to
everyone else is over
don't be robbed know better are you
stupid where are you no you're not in
the you're not gonna be in the bottom
corner where you were before so people
are gonna be in the top yeah you're
moving on up babbu moving on up for just
know that's probably copyright wait I
see someone on the road you see someone
on the road you see a shirtless man on
the road oh oh you're bouncing OH
Oh see you you don't see me oh crap
there you are ah I shrank Ilmenau you
try to swing me I stop you jumped it
looked like you swung at me what the
hell you jump you cover your face
apparently they do it again yeah that's
probably killing our food supply
alright let's go let's get to work gosh
god damn those [ __ ] are killing up
God okay there was a clearing over here
or something let's just try - should we
make like a shelter or anything I mean
we really need us to kill some more
animals till we can make frickin
sleeping bags yes very true so where you
need to focus on is killing some animals
it's extrude our rage upon this world
for what it has brought to us now where
are the animal ah they're usually out in
sort of these grassy clearings okay well
that's a deer over there and I see a
poor Oh - boar over here
okay I am ya know over over this way
there's some poor hanging around and I'm
gonna figure out how to make up you need
cloth to make a hunting bow hide
handcannon hatchet hunting bow okay we
need to kill animal that's basically the
longest order oh you're way over there
oh I found a boar I'm gonna kill this
boar dead running away from where you
were to run it
whoop whoop is chod that sound so bad
whoomp
alright I have enough cloth to make to
make one sleeping bag I believe okay
cool alright this will be perfect get
the sleeping bags and get in a shelter
block a place to spawn
we never get off the server Evers is
this is our place forever now those guys
who we call jerks they're our friends
forever uh or enemies for life how much
cloth you got I have six cloth all right
you need eleven what you need nine more
I mean I work okay what's up bo is that
a boars that's war that's a board that's
all my god let's get it that's killing
we're still broom off right here you
kill it I'm gonna get some more wooden
stuff okay I know we can make a shelter
with sleeping bags
and a campfire gonna be great you know
what's so we have our own shelters
that's the doors lock or what um you you
don't have to build a shelter you can
just build like wood walls and then you
can just um you know trying to do do it
however you want it let you know how
those towers were built and stuff like
that yeah just do that fine well I feel
like the walls are probably a less
effective use of our resources maybe but
I mean that way you could put two doors
on at least all right so did you get
that boar I got that board how much
thought you got now I have ten cloth
he's five more good are we gonna qualify
get two more then how many donuts would
I have left
haha this is gonna be the quoting Brian
Regan our I hope that's not copyrighted
I'm sure it is
nah I had to be fine and I don't think
that works that way
or does it I don't know I don't know by
the way did you notice that that Sun is
really freakin big it's a gigantic ass
done protip this is not earth are you
mine I mean it kinda is I mean you look
sorta human but just a little off I'm I
am hungry that's bad I know I guess I'm
gonna eat some of my 27 raw chicken
breasts yeah it takes off like ten
health at a time so just gonna be
careful yeah also you lose health
oh wait does it lieutenant the over
timer well my god when you throw up you
get more hungry Oh what the hell and
what's the point what is the point how
do we okay you know what there's a bunch
of animals over here I'm gonna kill them
all and we're gonna just go on our merry
way I'm gonna matter the bear oh I'm in
trouble I'm gonna make my uh my bed
right now oh you had enough for a bed
why didn't you help me I got like four
one bed I'm making passing runs on this
board to try to harvest it while there's
bears on my ass oh oh I got one some
animal fat and yeah oh come on I had
that okay got a chicken breasts
ah this bear wants my oh come on oh I'm
bleeding I'm bleeding I'm bleeding I'm
bleeding
oh damn bear [ __ ] this bear oh my god
okay I've got sleeping bag I just need
I'm gonna make a wood shelter and a door
and call it a night I've got two bears
on my ass
well you shouldn't uh that huh what did
I do shut up I didn't do anything I was
trying to live in now Kenny why are you
I mean I I mean a field of bears and
boars that's all I am well don't bring
him over here
what am I gonna do you're just gonna
leave me to die I honestly have no idea
were you even with I went why'd you run
away from the field that was full of
urine wars I am in the field of deer and
boars well I'm gonna die oh I'm going to
die I've got three bears now aren't you
proud of me I got three bears what did I
do I didn't do anything just trying to
get friggin Glatt alright stay alive I'm
gonna get my shelter set up as soon as
it's done crafting die of hunger come
back and save your life there's no back
I'm just gonna run away far enough but
I'm leaving my boars bind oh they're
still coming oh my god damn ago I might
actually get a shelter constructed oh
just as you'd I shouldn't even those
chicken breasts me god that was the
worst decision I've ever made I could do
it man was it worth it no or you're
gonna die okay I'm just gonna put my
wood filter in the middle of the steel
world is your worst that you can find it
okay probably easier for other players
to spot too don't care oh god damn it
come on cloth cluck-cluck somebody do it
happen I might do have now I'm 14 ah ah
I know what you're not the one being
chased around by bears oh my gosh I have
a camp I have a handle got it ah I got I
got enough okay I'm headed toward where
are you I'm in that field where we first
discovered dungeon oh and the Boers were
there it's a big field thing there's a
there's now a shelter and it can't
fire is gonna be in front of it in just
a second as soon as it's done crafting I
may be bringing bears with me oh god I
wonder if a wood shelter will hold out
bears
now all the doors open so just like run
inside as soon as you get here and oh
where are you I don't see it's getting
dark Bob getting dark I don't see any
movement oh I feel very lonely I think
I'm heading toward oh I see you I see
you I see do you see me jumping up and
down for I see you a wooden box by a
tree yeah that's it yeah buddy
all right I have got my sleeping bag in
here get in here I'm getting in ah
I mean haha now I'm gonna make my
sleeping bag and we're gonna be just
fine I need 30 seconds but I'm dying of
hunger and I've got a wood some wood
storage boxes yeah and I'm gonna set
them down or something
oh we're gonna we're doing it guys
everybody watching we're doing it right
kinda I can't place that there hang on
oh can you move a little lower yes I'll
light our light it up for us that better
is it better
apparently I can't place that there oh
that's why my bed's gonna go put it out
that oh no people feel this children
needs to be bigger do you make your make
your own make my own shelter yeah well I
think I have enough to make a shelter
here no hang on I'm gonna yeah I will
make a shelter hang on I need I have
enough to make one let me crap before
y'all crafted okay if you say so
and then we do need a campfire or
something okay I got my sleeping bag oh
my god dude what we did it we didn't do
it yet make your sleeping bag it's made
but I mean what do I do about it but
just put it down I assume I don't know
you can't use it or anything hang on
what what you can put it down and pick
it up so I assume if it's placed by you
it's like it's your camp well I put it
down right here that's fine it's so this
is our camp now isn't is that how it
works we'll find out when I die of
hunger oh my god I'm gonna put all of my
valuables into this thing oh I'm putting
a wood shelter into the wood bunk and
I'm gonna tink I'm gonna take the wood
joists
my hunger pretty quickly but I need to
make a door right yeah yeah I'm gonna
make a campfire
while I'm hopefully before I die and
then I'll put that outside for a door I
guess that is pretty nice considering it
oh my god or dude I'm so excited right
now
no idea uh-huh we've been we've been
trying hard guys we've been trying real
hard to get this going here I've never
been so excited about such a minor
accomplishment in a video game
well that excitement translates to the
fans out there who's excited like
favorite comment subscribe YouTube
Facebook MySpace Twitter Instagram
tumblr um snapchat I don't uh I guess
yet you all do all those things
Foursquare okay the box is entirely if
you like us and our excitement do all
those things and stuff and stuff okay
uh can I get out the door Rob oh my god
it's dark oh yeah yeah what are you
gonna place it and then use it and then
close the door oh yeah baby oh yeah baby
I'm going to try to make my home
we're comforted right now that's
happening does that mean we're currently
you open this door please I'm going to
set up my camera right next to yours
wait no right right whoa hey whoa hey
whoa oh my gosh it gets completely dark
in here I don't and put my campfire I'm
gonna make a campfire and also set it in
here I guess and put door on OOP yeah I
did it I did it
my sleeping bags not in here but at
least we got it right yeah we have we
have shelters now can you open the door
can you let me in uh yeah thank you
alright so we did it guys yeah all right
so now we have a platform with which to
pick it up later so thank you guys so
much for believing in us as we do this
so hope you're enjoying the series we
know we are I know so thank you
everybody
as always
Oh
for we
wait third
Oh
Oh what's going on
good god oh my god that's that's the
hardest thing I've ever done in my life
I know and it shouldn't be that hard but
a parent or whatever oh no I'm dying of
hunger and I'm taking all the wood with
me apparently
okay oh yeah I think if you die you drop
like a backpack on the ground okay well
I've won help left I'm gonna die of
hunger I want to see what habitat oh you
just fell through the ground Oh
literally this is like the moment of
truth Eddie all of everything that we
just went through all right at a camp
you better bullet you better respond in
here because I'm locked inside of your
cabin gadget am i back oh yes wow that
was is it like an orgasm oh my god now I
don't know if the same is happening to
me but um hopefully pick up your ass or
your hatchet and kill you kill me and
we'll open this door let me die outside
that way oh and when you respawn you get
medkit that's kind of a hey that's nice
now we have bonus med kits cool now open
that door we have to hand stones okay
working on it and get the hatchet and
smack me in the forehead you just hit me
real hard okay now what happened what
should happen is I should drop my stuff
I'm not dead yet please keep hitting
there I go oh yeah all your stuff is in
there oh cool well there you go
that works out on respawn at camp Chavez
Garriga oh look at me huh right there
looking over my corpse give me yeah wait
let me give me all that I'm just gonna
take it I know give it all to be all
right we did it we did it we did it oh
my god